covet cases this morning i'm training
with my trainer okay
and he says who's on the podcast today i
said the press secretary uh uh pusha uh
governor desantis as press secretary he
says oh really i said yes i said let me
ask you for you what questions do you
have do you know who she says i don't
follow politics i said but what question
do you have for desantis he says well i
want to know how he's going to handle
this covet breakout in the state of
florida okay
now you got to realize there's people
that follow stories there's people that
follow headlines there's people that
kind of see what the news says and
that's it right with colby cases
can you pull up where florida ranks in
number of cases
uh of
a number of cases for i don't know let's
do for
period ever go new kit and new cases all
time right there if you can make it a
little bit bigger so the rest of us can
see it okay florida what is the number
do they show the numbers
uh uh uh no you got to do rankings go
rank and go a little lower there's a
website right there go a little lower a
little lower little lower lower uh buy
states
okay the one that says bi-state
okay just go up forget about florida
just type in covet cases by state take
florida covet cases by state you got it
by state all right let's go there
go the lord there should be a ranking
lower lower lower right there click on
that
and
see where florida ranks lord is going to
be third because we're the third biggest
population i totally get that and i want
to i want to go to
what site would you say for him to go
can you help them out to see what site
to go to there's a website that shows
all of it a data tracker that's the one
kova data tracker uh you just found it
yeah go to covid
covet data tracker
by state
yeah the cdc has a lot of information
here we go cdc go to
okay anyway so you have a hard time
finding it let me just ask you so the
questions with covet cases so the
criticism people get when i go to
california i'll go to new york i'll go
to greenwich i'll go to different
left blue states right they'll say where
are you from florida oh my gosh how are
things there
oh my gosh it must be really bad over
there is it pretty bad with covet cases
i hear the hospitals are full i hear
it's just people are dying left and
right it's tragic what's going on
florida how are you protecting yourself
you would be amazed how many people
have an interpretation of what they
think is going on in florida so what
would you say about the handling of
covet cases in florida what are some
data you can share with the audience
i would say number one cases are not the
most serious metric to be focused on
because a lot of cases particularly
among people who were vaccinated or
people who are just in lower risk groups
the case might just be a positive test
you might not even be sick necessarily
or you might have like a slight cold or
something so what we've kind of focused
on more is preventing hospitalization so
helping the most vulnerable people who
are actually vulnerable to severe
outcomes so if you look at the data i
mean i think the most important data
point to look at is deaths
over time since the beginning of the
pandemic um
why because obviously
we want to save lives so new york's
death per capita
is higher than florida's despite the
fact that new york has so many
restrictions and florida does not and
our population is older than new york's
on average so we have a higher risk
population
for all states florida is i think number
17 or 18 in terms of number of deaths
which is a little bit higher than
average but again considering how old
our population is viewed just for the
age it's lower and
considering the fact that so many of
those states that are higher than us in
deaths had these restrictions i think it
just goes to show you like there's no
real so that's a good chart there's no
real reason
um to say that these restrictions
actually worked and so i think that's
the thing i think when you're talking to
people from other states who have heard
this narrative in the media the media
has pushed it because they don't want
people to see that everything is fine in
florida and to see that we're actually
doing better than a lot of the
restrictive states and the mandate
states why because for whatever reason
media supports the restrictions more
okay go to war i just found it go to
world
okay i'm just going to send you this
link it's world on uh world ohmmeters
world that's a good one that's the one
if you go to world oh meters
and go down and make it a little bit
bigger so the audience can see keep
going down down down let's see if the
state shows up so when i'm looking at
i'm seeing the states there we go okay
so uh buy cases go total cases
um make it bigger make it bigger make it
bigger okay so florida is number three
okay california's got seven point six
seven million
uh texas got six million cases floors
got
5.395 so if
if that number is the way it is
florida should also be ranked third in a
number of people that have died due to
covets can you go to total
debts that we've had go to total bets
and let's see where it ranks there
it is yeah okay so it's third as well
it really should be total deaths by a
hundred thousand people that's that's
right per capita exactly so per capita
it's ranked 17th or 18th we've been
literally middle of the pack the entire
so so then here's a question here's a
question because because that link i
just sent you tyler there's another good
because if they if they if a nicki who's
running for governor is talking about
how you know desantis running this place
like a dictator okay
and you have newsom
and you have cuomo you have new york you
have illinois who everything's been
mandate mandate mandate
how is it that florida's you know number
of debts knowing this is a retirement
state this is where people come to
panama city to retire people come to
palm beach people come to places like
that yeah the villages so why do you
think what were some things desantis did
or the state of florida did where the
death per capita isn't third place where
the number of cases is third place in
for florida
i mean it's a great question i think
number one all of these restrictions
that were trotted out like from the
lockdowns to the vaccine mandates mask
mandates none of that stuff was proven
to work this is the first like we've had
pandemics before in our lifetimes the
last one being h1n1 in the 2000s and
nobody ever talked about a mask mandate
like it just it wasn't on the radar and
so like
for whatever reason all these new things
were introduced in the last couple of
years with kovid but they haven't made a
difference now as far as what desantis
has actually done though he has focused
on well one he reads the research he
talks to different doctors like jay
bodacharya from stanford martin culdorf
from harvard like
doctors who who know their stuff but
they have a little bit of a different
perspective from the overarching
narrative and also if you know our
surgeon general dr joseph ladapo he just
recently joined from ucla um brilliant
guy harvard md phd and he has said the
same thing you know the restrictions
haven't worked we should be focusing on
overall health of the population and
taking care of the people that actually
are vulnerable to serious outcomes
statistically that's older people so
governor desantis when the vaccines
became available prioritize seniors 65
and older the cdc was saying you should
prioritize frontline workers but that
could be 20 year olds and he's like well
you know they're they're not at as much
risk and that's just a fact so we're
giving it to seniors cdc later updated
its guidelines next thing
he promoted treatments and still does
monoclonal antibody treatments saved
thousands of lives when the delta surge
was hitting florida very hard in summer
we really i think governor desantis
really pioneered that like opening all
the state treatment sites 25 sites
around the state where you can make an
appointment as soon as you test positive
go and get the treatment no prescription
needed and it kept a lot of folks out of
the hospital so they they would have had
to go to the hospital if they wouldn't
have gotten that outpatient treatment
but they they didn't have to be thanks
to this and so now other states are
doing it the binary administration has
not supported this they actually just
yesterday pulled two of the monoclonal
antibodies off the market without
showing us the data saying that they say
it's not effective against omicron but
they haven't shown us any data on that
so it's very weird
but um but
yeah that's where the governor stood
apart i think that's why our death rate
is lower than many of these lockdown
states like new york for example or new
jersey or rhode island because we have
focused on predicting the vulnerable and
focused on treatment so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you